it's great to have back on the program
today Andrew Seidel who's a civil rights
and constitutional attorney with
Americans United for separation of
church and state his new book is
American Crusade how the Supreme Court
is weaponizing religious freedom Andrew
really great to have you back on today
oh it's a pleasure to be back thank you
so much for having me so you know we
knew we predicted it was sort of written
on the wall that after the 2015 Supreme
Court decision that said you can no
longer ban gay marriage at the state
level it wasn't that the idea of
weaponizing homophobia in the law was
going to go away it was simply going to
move to sort of other venues one of them
was going to be attempts at employer
discrimination on the basis of religious
freedom and and sort of using religious
freedom the baker case as many have
talked about the cake baker Etc can you
talk a little bit about how the Supreme
Court which is now one of the most
conservative Supreme Courts we've had in
a while has assisted in doing exactly
this
oh absolutely I mean religious freedom
has long been a shield right it's
defended the minority against the
tyranny of the majority it's it's
defended us all against government
overreach and and never in our history
has it been a license to violate the
rights of other people or or to infringe
their rights in any way but this packed
Supreme Court
collaborating with a network of
well-funded powerful Christian
nationalist organizations is changing
that and these Crusaders I mean they are
weaponizing religious freedom and we've
seen it for the last decade in case
after case they are literally reshaping
the legal meaning of the First Amendment
and they're turning that protection into
a weapon that conservative Christians
can use to injure other people to
violate their rights and to impose their
religion on us all and so American
Crusade the new book tells the true
stories behind those Blockbuster cases
that are actually rewriting our
Constitution and it does so without the
the legalese and jargon that we lawyers
like to hide behind because I really
wanted everybody to be able to
understand the threat and see just how
radical and dangerous these Crusaders
and this these Supreme Court opinions
truly are and explaining these without
legalese is often so important just for
getting the average person to understand
what's kind of fundamentally at issue so
let's talk about the so-called gay
wedding cake case which is masterpiece
cake shop V the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission ultimately in in layperson's
terms why did the Court rule in favor of
the baker who did not want to bake the
cake
essentially the court manufactured
hostility against the bakery's religion
what it what the court said was that the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission which
is in charge of enforcing the state
civil rights law yes basically it was
mean and said mean things about the
baker's religion and that tainted the
whole process and effectively what it
did was it gave the baker a get out of
jail free card now it didn't decide the
central issue does religious freedom
equal a license to discriminate and a
big part of that is because Charlie and
David the couple involved in this case
really did a great job of speaking out
about putting a face on this
discrimination and it made it difficult
I think for the court to make that
decision I also I will say that the
court is considering a case right now
303 creative versus Elena's out of
Colorado
that is going to decide that issue at
least on the First Amendment Free Speech
grounds
um probably this term and there is no
couple that's been been discriminated
against I think I think the Court's
going to finally do what it was not able
to do back in 2018. what do you make of
the cases that have to do with crosses
and you know Ten Commandments uh plaques
and and sorts of things on public lands
and or at government buildings like is
is there ever a time when that is
acceptable even though it appears to be
an establishment of one particular
religion over others and over
non-religion by the government and what
does the Supreme Court said about that
I mean historically the Supreme Court's
actually been pretty good about for the
most part striking down these overt
religious Expressions uh except that
we've seen that change in the last few
years
um especially uh with the Bladensburg
cross case that we saw now I mean one of
the things that was really striking to
me in writing this is I first of all
I've been in the trenches fighting these
cases for a decade I mean this is this
is my career I've I've litigated these
cases I've briefed them I've been in
front of Courts arguing these cases and
the the thing that I think a lot of
people don't understand it's partly
because this is part of the Crusade is
that these questions are actually really
simple to answer for the most part like
when religion and the law Collide the
answers the to the questions raised are
not that difficult for us to figure out
and I draw three simple lines in the
book you know synthesizing basically 200
plus years of precedent and the third
line is the separation of church and
state and it's pretty simple our
government has no religion to to
exercise you know so putting up a cross
on government property it is
inappropriate
um our and I think a lot of times we
fa we we talk about the separation of
church and state in vague terms and not
in terms that actually impact people in
their everyday lives right
um and it really is at its most basic
level in abuse of power when that line
is violated you have a public official
abusing state power
to impose their personal religion on
other people and that's a big problem
that's what for instance what we saw in
the case of the praying football coach
this past term at the court right this
is a state actor abusing his power to
impose his personal religion on other
people's kids and you have the Supreme
Court rubber stamping it and saying yep
we're cool with that yeah we've been
covering that since the beginning so if
I recall the most recent news on that is
uh that the prayer was okay uh at the at
the center at the 50-yard line
um it was not a sort of coercive despite
the fact that this was the coach in a
position of power and authority and that
it's totally obvious that football
players high school kids might
reasonably feel that if they don't
participate maybe playing time is
jeopardized that they are they are in a
position of subservience for lack of a
better term there and apparently the
decision is that it was actually okay
and the coach is going to be reinstated
if I recall correctly
you do and there are a couple things to
to hit on it so first of all this is one
of the cases that I cover in the book
and I actually have an update on my
website going over all of the newest
materials yeah that's been coming out
and in that case we know for a fact that
students felt pressured right there's
there's no question students felt
pressured by their coach they felt that
they had to pray to play and you
actually had the Crusader involved in
this case first Liberty Institute which
is the the Christian nationalist
organization that brought the case all
the way to the Supreme Court yes you you
have them spinning what one of the lower
judges called a quote deceitful
narrative
right and that they're making up this
this idea of oh he's just saying a
private personal prayer
on the 50-yard line surrounded by
students surrounded by staff I mean it's
ridiculous to the point where in her
descent Justice Sonia Sotomayor is
including photographs to show that this
is a deceitful narrative
um in the lower courts one of the judges
actually puts the claims that first
Liberty Institute makes in his chart
beside what actually happened in reality
but the crazy thing about it and which
to me highlights the fact that our court
is packed and gone and is complicit in
this Crusade is that first Liberty
Institute instead of running and hiding
and burying their head in the sand after
a judge said they were spinning a
deceitful narrative they appealed to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
adopted the ultra-conservative block on
the Supreme Court rather adopted that
deceitful narrative wholesale
they just lied to us all when you look
at the current Supreme Court I know that
it can be hard to say this overall but
maybe specifically as it applies to the
areas that you're talking about here is
this the most right-wing Supreme Court
that there has been in I mean how long
I mean certainly Our Generation for sure
I mean that this is one of the things
though that I think we really need to do
and this is what I try to do in American
Crusaders we have to unshackle our minds
from the belief that the Supreme Court
is an impartial Arbiter of Truth and
justice The Crusade depends upon people
believing their Smith but look Mitch
McConnell and Donald Trump and Leonard
Leo they cheated and stole and packed
the courts to put their collaborators in
place not because those collaborators
would administer justice even-handedly
but because they wouldn't specifically
because they wouldn't yeah exactly I
mean if they if they just wanted Justice
administered even-handedly Merrick
garland would have gotten a hearing
instead they spent 540 million dollars
packing the core with people they knew
would decide cases in in their way but
to answer your question I think what
we're actually seeing is a very
conservative regressive institution
returning to its mean I mean this is one
of the things that came across when I
was researching the book like the
Supreme Court historically is a very
conservative body we think of it as the
war in court we think of it as the court
that gave us Brown versus Board of
Education in Miranda versus Arizona and
Gideon versus Wainwright which says that
you have a right to counsel when you are
accused of a crime but but that's that's
kind of of the outlier in our Court's
history this is the court of Plessy
versus Ferguson and separate is equal of
of Dred Scott and fugitive slave laws of
trying to suffocate the New Deal in the
Cradle after it was one with the blood
of so many Americans during the Civil
War of Japanese internment camps of
Muslim bans of billionaires and
corporations and political
gerrymandering and vote suppression and
now of abolishing abortion and
reproductive freedom in the name of
their narrow religious beliefs so this
is the most conservative Court in our
lifetimes but certainly not in the
lifetime of this country last thing I
wanted to ask you about there were so
many cases particularly early during the
covid pandemic related to restrictions
on public Gatherings and also in some
cases related to masks and other things
and individuals would start to assert
religious Arguments for example that the
Gathering was really a religious
gathering due to opposition based on
religion to some of the guidelines that
were put in place or religious claims
related to masks or vaccines or whatever
the case may be can you talk a little
bit about that in the context of these
other things that we're talking about
and is it similar is it bogus how does a
court uh how does the current Court
think about such claims in that context
so this is actually one of one of the
chapters that I spend a lot of time on
because it really does crystallize and
highlight exactly the problem with this
Crusade and how fallacious it is at its
most basic level yeah um so I I go
through all the covage cases the big
coveted cases that hit the Supreme Court
both before and after Amy Coney Barrett
which is kind of the Tipping Point and
one of the things that became really
clear is that it's all kind of nonsense
if if you look at the other first
amendment claims that are made Free
Speech claims free assembly claims all
of those cases failed all of those cases
failed the only cases that one were
religious freedom claims and they only
won before Trump judges and Republican
appointed judges uh like 80 percent of
the time they won before Trump judges 50
of the time before Republican judges and
never before a Democrat appointed judge
which is the right call by the way and
is is what our precedence says I mean
there's very clear precedent going back
a hundred years saying that your
religious freedom does not include a
right to risk the health and safety of
every other citizen in this country
especially during a pandemic I mean this
is a very clear line right this is what
I'm talking about with the weaponizing
of religious freedom they are turning
that protection into a weapon to harm
and impose on others and violate their
rights and nothing could be more clear
than that than saying during a pandemic
you can risk everybody else's lives
uh the book is excellent it's called
American Crusade how the Supreme Court
is weaponizing religious freedom there
are signed copies available using the
link that we'll put in the video
description on YouTube we have been
speaking with the book's author Andrew
Seidel who is a civil rights and
constitutional attorney Andrew always
great having you on I appreciate it
thank you so much always pleasure my
friend